my biggest fear in life is that one day  if i ever get judged  by something someone some some energy  force  that go up there and i failed the  mission  whatever whatever force up there thought  i was supposed to be some badass  and i went up there underachieved you  know i want that force up there  that knows everything to be writing as  i'm living saying i had no [ __ ] idea  he even had this in him  so i want to just be the best i [ __ ]  can and a lot of people say that  i truly mean that  and what is it that you have to learn  i still learn me  you know i i still feel there's you know  there's times where  as a human being i'm a human and you you  still fall back in these in these ruts  of life  where you think that you had a permanent  fix because i've done all that  nothing's a permanent fix man  that's why i grind every day  because nothing is permanent